no [ __ ] [ __ ] god damn it this video is
in ten minutes yet what the [ __ ] do I do
it's [ __ ] January there's such a lack
of ad revenue already I'm just gonna
have to learn from the best
to extend this video through 10 minutes
am i talking slow is that obvious what
I'm doing here Oh leafy master of title
carts
[Music]
we show hats 11 seconds with no content
actually it's never mind that that's 17
minutes with no content I'm just kidding
I'm kidding I'm kidding
Calvin I'm joking okay I get it I get it
I need it I need an intro I need to
bring it back roll the in front are we
at 10 minutes yet [ __ ] okay I got it
Casey nice tight he does these
transitional shot let's have a look
[Music]
[ __ ] okay just roll a random a random
ass stock image footage okay
are we at 10 minutes yet please [ __ ]
January do you see what happens with the
ad revenue MMS bad this is real bad I'm
gonna have to find a real job real soon
if this continues oh I got it in my last
video don't worry about the order in
this video I know it's a little messy ok
a baby push button to yesterday's video
I said I was gonna put the top comment
the top comment on that wall now I
haven't checked alright I I have not
checked so it could be anything right
now let's let's see what it is well I'm
a bit nervous
hey random people scrolling through the
comments Happy New Year and I love you
[Music]
that's the top cumin I gave you guys
permission to put [ __ ] anything in
the background of my video and the top
comment is a [ __ ] self advertise I
thought at least I you guys to learn
better then believe in some random ass
[ __ ] comment saying I love you what
the [ __ ] does that mean
and you got a homeless guy from the
street tell you I love you doesn't mean
anything words don't mean [ __ ] unless it
comes with real meaning and from a
person but you respect or at least know
who the [ __ ] it is they'll excuse me
while I'm pudding
[Music]
let's just go back to what the video is
about I don't [ __ ] give a [ __ ] hey
how's it going bros welcome to another
original video idea try not to laugh ha
I failed already but there's a catch
since you guys loved my moustache so
much thank you very much by the way I
really appreciate all the nice feedback
about my new your parents you know here
I was thinking I look cool finally I
find a hip new look that fits me and my
personality but I guess that's not good
enough so if I laugh I will shave a
piece of my mustache as much as it pains
me before and if I run out of mustache
I'll shave this dog
[Music]
let's do this the first video is true
it's this kind of video where you know
you're gonna laugh even before you watch
it there's no way I could not have
laughed at that it's just a little piece
whatever I think we all know where this
is heading
I like it it's a good look I really hope
I don't have to laugh again oh hello
okay I don't believe I I need to do a
sinus rinse right [ __ ] that don't
want the world to see me didn't laugh
thank you very much next
oh no no that was an after giggle they
don't count my cat is crazy I didn't
laugh
number one why were you filming your cat
in a [ __ ] garden house number two
what the [ __ ] why did that cat go what
was so important to that cat why do I
feel like I'm ray william johnson
deconstructing and [ __ ] [ __ ] oh we're
getting there I kind of like it do you
like moving on we're gonna interview
Eric why had mayor who climbed the
highest mountain in the world Mount
Everest cut he's gay I mean he's gay
excuse me he's blind so we're here about
that okay as we head to break I'll look
for six
I know what I left
that's the break wasn't interview Eric
why hit mayor who climbed the highest
mountain in the world Mount Everest but
yeah but he's gay garlic rice like a
racing car hey sorry mister call I was
calling you back to let you know that I
love you and I miss you I really I
really want you to call me back and I'm
sorry I missed your phone call and that
I I know you're done so so when you get
this can you call me back I love you and
I miss you
[Music]
next video these are really good these
are really good clips this time why were
you watching that they're just blind
they're just blowing don't worry about
it it's nothing wrong with watching
blind people early stages of a yaoi
fangirl [ __ ] it
all right it was worth it oh no okay I
want to show you a little secret
oh okay a guy taught me from the
American Rangers great and he always
said you know in a tactical situation
the sound of velcro you can hear it a
mile away and everybody knows that sound
of velcro's that's true oh and enjoy him
so here we have a velcro pouch and this
is the sound that gives you away in the
tactical situation and so he taught me a
method of opening the velcro so that if
you do it no one will hear the velcro
okay what is that real fast and so the
velcro I've got it on as best as I can
get it on if this opposed to be funny
this is what he taught me okay
[Music]
take your arm outwards 45 degrees from
the front and lift your arm up as far as
here we go I think it's time
[Music]
that was tryna - life challenge mustache
edition if you enjoyed this video I
think you are gonna enjoy this one this
is the one you want and watch next to
make sure that you click right here for
another video
oh boy it's one of my favorite actually
what's that oh you already clicked then
why am I even here